what's up taylor um not much um
basically it's just a simple question
go for it let's do it so my brother
i love him dearly um he
probably doesn't always think that i do
um
he i guess he sort of craves
physical affection okay um and so he's
always wanted me to hug him or want to
give me a hug
before bed or before i
go off to work before he goes off to
work and
sometimes i am just not in the mood and
so
i try to push him away say like you
don't need to
always hug me whatever um
and he sort of takes it personal to be
honest he'll get mad at me
sure so i don't know so how old are you
i'm 21 21 how old your brother
20 20. so have you
always had a
a awkward physical relationship with him
do you not like it when he hugs you
because he
hugs you inappropriately he violates
your physical boundaries or you just
don't want to hug him um
probably a mix of both it's just like i
don't know
okay um
so here's here's the the brass tacks of
it you
control your body and you
are um entitled to
and responsible for setting your
boundaries
whatever they may be and you are allowed
to have them
you are fully encouraged to have them
and i want to proclaim for you
permission to speak them on the you
don't need my permission you're endowed
by those
by god himself you are allowed to speak
those boundaries into the universe
and you're allowed to demand that other
people respect those physical boundaries
whether that's your dad your mom your
brother
anybody okay yep
what what is really helpful is
clear boundaries meaning
when somebody comes in to hug you and
you go ah
then you are maintaining your boundaries
you have a right to do that
but it's become a social issue too
if you go to your brother and one one
day before night time
and say hey from this point forward
we're not hugging anymore
we are high-fiving each other with two
high-five hands
and i'm not going to give you a hug
anymore or we're just gonna side hug
one arm side hug that's it that's the
brother
hug then yep he can get over it
and if he chooses to throw a temper
tantrum that's his immaturity
not yours okay
and so what i would recommend that you
do is be very vocal and very direct
about what your boundaries are
here is what i will accept when it comes
to physical touch in my home
with my brother period end of story
and then he can get over that and you
can tell them i love you
i love you a lot these are my physical
boundaries
with my son my wife like my son is
uh freakishly tall like like
a huge and so at a young age he would go
hug women and he would put his head
right between their chest like right in
their chest
and it was uncomfortable for people and
he was
like four or five and six and he was
huge and he would nuzzle
up and it would make you get to see
people going like huh gosh
and so my wife like we had a hard
straight talk with him
about these are private parts when you
hug somebody
you will shake their hand and if you
want to give them a hug you will side
hug them
and he even had a funny response he's
like but i like my head there i mean it
was he was just a sweet little boy
um he even said once i don't know if i'm
allowed to say this james he was like
but can i just put it between like and
we're like nope nope dude you can't do
that right
um but he was just a sweet kid wanting
to hug
he didn't have any there was nothing
sexual about it there was nothing he
just wanted to
um be connected and it took us some very
direct these are private parts
these are not for you and um you will
hug me like this
and you will shake hands to strangers
and that's where it's going to be and he
adapted and he got it
and um so i want to fully 100 tailor
empower you whatever your boundaries are
physically
own them be proud about them don't uh
apologize for them and speak them out
into the world so that other people
know unequivocally what they are is that
cool
and yeah and i feel like part of it is
probably he he sort of went through a
rough breakup a while back and
it's sort of been ever since then that
he's been
a little bit more i guess wanting to
he probably just craved some sort of
affection sure
and affection's good violating
somebody's boundaries is not
and your job as his sister is not to
meet
his need for physical touch
not to meet his need his longing for
intimacy that's not a sister's job a
sister's job is to love their little
brother
right right a brother's job is to love
his brother right
um that's not that's not their job
and so it might be that you can hold his
hand hold his hand tight
and with both of your hands and make
sure he feels loved
you can put your head on his shoulder
you can put his head on your shoulder
you can lock elbows with him you can
side hug the heck out of him
but you get to decide here's my
boundaries
and i'm not comfortable with anything
other than that and you can be very
forthright with him
okay and that is not a mark on you and i
know i've said it over and over in this
call i want
everyone to hear that over and over and
over everyone gets to own
the autonomy of their body and
the more that people feel comfortable
saying i am comfortable with this level
of interaction
i'm not comfortable with this um the
more empowered they feel
and the more people can honor them with
hospitality when they come into contact
with him
he may not know he may just think you're
being an annoying sister he may not
realize
um you are violating being violated
right
yeah right and so i want to tell you
i'm proud of you for setting boundaries
and i'm proud of you for trying to honor
him at the same time
own your body good for you
thank you good for you i'm really
grateful for that call